parts of india including capital delhi
have witnessed the highest ever recorded
summer temperatures in more than 120
years putting new lives and livelihoods
at risk
eighteen-year-old bhumi lives with her
family of eight in a south daily slum
the temperature is so high that she has
put on a clay mask to cool her face
[Music]
india have already crossed 47 degrees
celsius 160 degrees fahrenheit and those
worst affected are the people living on
minimum wages who lack access
to
foreign
[Music]
the meteorological department expects
the severe heat waves to continue to
stretch through most of the air
this means millions of indians will have
to continue to endure dangerously high
heat levels in addition to power and
water shortages
this is a free school running under the
bridge
underprivileged students take classes in
the open air without air conditioning or
a fan teacher sha mato says he struggles
to keep students safe and hydrated
[Music]
but the waters are still warm to touch
climate scientists say this year's
heat is undoubtedly a sign of mercenary
[Music]
you